Speaker 1: Let's start today with the topic of
protests. Many of you have been writing to me
and in different versions, asking, do I think
there are going to be violent protests or even
riots if and when Donald Trump is indicted,
arrested, surrenders, arraigned. Whatever the
case may be. Increasingly, it seems as though that
is going to be sometime over the next seven days,
if at all. I am I'm couching all of these things
with, if at all, so I won't say it every time.
But that's the speculation right now. And
Donald Trump called for protests in some
of those original truth social posts that first
started this entire conversation about the arrest.
Donald Trump putting protests, protest protests,
its time on and on and on. And of course, we're
well positioned to be concerned. It's reasonable
to be concerned about violent protests from MAGA
because violent protests from MAGA are, in a way,
how we got into this mess in the first place with
what happened on January 6th of 2021. But there's
a difference. The early signals are that it's
really not clear. The MAGA people are willing to
go out and do the protesting. In this particular
case, partially this was evidenced by Monday
evening's completely flaccid, pathetic rally,
just an impotent rally in Lower Manhattan where,
like there were more media people than protesters
and there were maybe a couple dozen protesters.
We also had that video from Trump Tower yesterday
where five people were there holding signs saying
Trump won and one person blew a shofar. It's not
exactly an electric atmosphere of protesting
in defense of Donald Trump right now. Well,
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham appeared on Fox
and Friends yesterday, and he's using language
that raised the eyebrows of many. And the language
he's using is that if Trump is indicted, it will
blow up our country. And again, many of you taking
this as a sign that he's leading protesters to
maybe behave violently, violently. Let's listen
to what Lindsey had to say. So are you concerned
about the district attorney, Bragg, Alvin Bragg.
Speaker 2: Indicting President Trump next week in
an unprecedented way and the circus that would.
Speaker 1: Be around that is going to blow up our
country. And this is a bunch of B.S.. You've
had the prosecutor before, Bragg, Mr. Vance,
look at the case and pass on it. You had the U.S.
attorney in New York saying, I'm not going to do
it federally. There was an intervening cause
other than Trump running. One of the guys in
the DA's office wrote a book very critical of
Vance. You should have prosecuted Trump. You
let him off. And Bragg feels that pressure. He's
a George Soros backed prosecutor. Okay. So Lindsey
is on topic with all of the bullet points. But
that first line, if Trump is indicted, it will
blow up our country. Some are understanding to be
an allusion to violence that Lindsey is saying go
out there and do the violent stuff. Now, I'll be
very honest with you. I find Lindsey Graham to be
a completely deplorable two faced individual. He
for years now has bounced like a pinball between
playing the rational Republican who can step
back from MAGA insanity and tell things the
way they are sort of like pretending to be Mitt
Romney in a way, but then he will behave in ways
reminiscent of someone who should be evaluated
psychiatrically. For example, his unhinged rant
during the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation hearings
where Lindsey got all red in the face, screaming
at the top of his lungs about how no one has been
treated more poorly and unfairly and unjustly
than Brett Kavanaugh. So there are two Lindsey
Graham's. Lindsey Graham has no qualms morally
with suddenly inciting violence in the event that
Trump is arrested. But I think what the wrench
in this is going to be is that the Trump people
don't really seem to care enough to actually go
out and protest. Now, this may change if and
when Trump is arrested, but in other times I
would have said this is very dangerous. This is a
tinderbox that's about to explode. But right now,
I'm not really seeing the evidence of that. I'm
not seeing the rage and the engagement on the
ground that these right wingers insist is actually
out there ready to come out in defense of Trump.
And again, case in point, just look at the turnout
for the protest on Monday, which we covered in
Lower Manhattan, more media than protesters and
even our friend Jason Salvage from the Good Liars
getting multiple minutes of being interviewed
by right side broadcasting because they didn't
really have real protesters that were could
coherently speak. So normally I would say this
is extraordinarily dangerous. Now I say people
like Lindsey Graham are dangerous. Hopefully
they're being dangerous in an environment that
is not actually going to lead to violence.
That's the hope. Let's now look at another
example of one of these so-called protests.